so we've had a good two and a half three
hours here sometimes I'm in a time warp
when I do these interviews but we've
gotten incredibly valuable information
Wendy as we wrap up I would love to hear
a success story and if you could just do
us a favor maybe just leave out
identifying information that's kind of a
rule we have here sure okay don't
courage okay so let's see I think well
or a couple one would be from something
that was quite a while ago that I had
read a play by a writer and I was so
enamored of the story it was made and it
was on CBS and it was called it wound up
being called Sally Hemings an American
scandal and what I love about the story
is that she had written it and I had
first found out about it I think it was
either seven or nine years before it got
made and all I'll say is that the stars
were aligned and it was the fact that
what happened was I came close to
selling it within the first two years so
they had the project it was under option
I think when I was at Hearst
entertainment and came close but didn't
sell it and then one day the writer and
I read in the trades that Merchant Ivory
had a sultan movie called Jefferson in
Paris with Nick Nolte and the two of us
and this happens in the business and it
invariably I mean it will happens to
everyone and right now I have two
projects actually where there are other
competing projects in the marketplace
and we're trying to get our stunt first
but anyway so the writer and I we were
quite despondent and then was like all
right life goes on and one food friend
the other and you keep you know what's
the next project and you put your focus
there but I never forgot how much I
loved that script and so Merchant Ivory
movie was made and two years later I
felt like I would hear opportunities in
network television where they were
interested in doing they were doing
period pieces and you would haul me
which was a big producer at the time
doing lots of period films for Network
and so every couple years I would think
maybe there is a different
audience that we could get and reach
with and you know TV and I would seek
opportunities and I would call up the
writer and I would say is that script
still available and she'd say yes and
one of those times seven years later she
said yes as a matter of fact
such-and-such actress I was having lunch
with her manager and we talked about and
she might be interested in playing the
role so I wound up calling up CBS and
saying we don't have a you know
commitment but we have preliminary
interest from so-and-so
and she said we'll send it over and it
was originally written as a two-hour
movie and the network came back and said
you know what we think we might be
interested in turning it into a
miniseries but instead of making it so
much about Thomas Jefferson we'd like to
make it more much more Sally Hemings
point of view so we did we rolled up our
sleeves we spent a month working with
her preparing an outline to bring to the
network so we could show what the end of
night one was that would ensure people
there was enough of the cliffhanger that
people would come back for night two so
we could justify yes this is enough
material for a miniseries and the day we
wind up going in to pitch two days
before it wound up hitting a front page
of New York Times Wall Street Journal
iving Time magazine that they hadn't
done tests finally conclusively with
Thomas Jefferson and concluded from the
DNA that he in fact did have a long-term
relationship with Sally Hemings and that
they did have five children together so
all of our competitors were saying oh my
god you guys were so smart to be on it
and in the network two days after little
did they know that this was had started
about nine years earlier and as some
mature a lot of us have heard this
expression but it is a very good one
that success
is when preparedness meets opportunity
so if we didn't have though if I hadn't
fallen in love with this piece if the
writer hadn't written this wonderful
piece if in fact I I hadn't like
continued every two years to inquire and
see if there was a new opportunity then
you know it would and if we didn't do
our homework to really we spent a month
preparing to go in and I've seen very
good writers who have blown deals when
they don't prepare enough you said
something that caught my ear and I just
wanted to follow up and that is you've
seen writers blow a deal because they
weren't prepared okay so are they not
prepared to know what the the genre that
this network is is used to dealing with
actually it's biting more with sometimes
if you have a script it can be sell
itself but other times maybe you have a
pitch I mean I've seen very very late
established writers go in a room and
because they haven't prepared the pitch
really well and it kind of meanders and
it could be a really good story but it I
really am a big any advocate of
preparing and I reminded of seeing a lot
of people probably don't know Whoopi
Goldberg when she started out she was an
absolutely brilliant comedian and she
when I I saw her at a charity event and
man she killed it on stage and for her
to be there's no question that Genie
certain geniuses and comedy or great
ad-libbing and this and that but they're
also for her to be and with most of the
great comics they look so spontaneous
they work their butts off rehearsing and
rehearsing to be able to deliver so
smoothly so I do think it's important
for you if you're going to be pitching a
project to to be prepared and that's
what we as producers
to do when we were pitching the Sally
Hemings piece and it's what I had to do
all the time and when I'm working with
writers and we're going to go in and
pitch is you know we have to do the work
you